Thursday PFT ot Chris Sims birthday PFT
ot and we're still making your work
overtime Chris even though it's your
birthday you can eat your cake later
baby
and and we're gonna start as we as we do
how did you how did you figure birthday
show went by the way I think we're happy
with a little bit little tricks in the
little bit for you some of that was very
funny and embarrassing it was really
good it flustered me at the start of our
seven o'clock hour cuz I know when we
got into Jadeveon Clowney eve segment i
blabbered and couldn't finish thoughts
or anything but i got back on track i
got focused and now I'm on to Cincinnati
and I will say this I will say this two
years ago you used to do that all the
time you rarely do it I mean I really
have improved
I think anything else the more you do it
the better you get although some people
they get to a level and they never get
any better no matter how long they keep
doing it I'm kind of at that point but
yeah I it was funny because it took me
back to two years ago when I would be
sitting here saying when is this guy
gonna shut the hell up
so so it was fun it was well nostalgia
okay good good all right let's get right
to it and then we'll shut up for the
rest of the day NFLPA looking into the
Cowboys directly dealing with players
cutting around the agents and this is
amazing they've done this for years and
it's never really been a thing until
yesterday
when I saw Mike Darrow folo of NFL
Network kind of bravely berry throwing
throwing one of the owners of the
network under the bus by saying yeah
these guys that are notorious for
dealing directly with players and I
don't think people realized in part
because the Cowboys have been so blatant
about it that it's a problem yeah that
the agent who represents the player is
the representative of the NFL Players
Association certified by the Union
regulated by the Union you can't go
around that person and go right to the
player and say I forget about that guy
that guy's just trying to muck
complicate things we don't need a third
party involved in our affairs we can
work this deal out directly and then we
got to pay the guy 3% you're better off
without an agent altogether I mean the
owners would love the players to not
have a worse day well the Cowboys the
Cowboys act like some of them don't have
agents apparently Chris no I know and
you know just as much as the owners
would love if the players you know
negotiated the man the players would
love that the owners played
Paul they really would who's iki Elliot
would be really awesome if Jerry Jones
was playing defensive tackle for most
teams you know that's again I respect
this that Jerry Jones has these
relationships with his star players it's
really cool you could tell the players
love Jerry Jones and Steven Jones
because they do feel like ownerships in
their corner maybe more than other
football teams and it does look that way
to me on the outside looking in but at
the end of the day I mean come on I mean
the agents are schooled at this they are
professionals at negotiating and so are
the owners players are not this is not
their avenue of success more times than
not yeah there's a few you know one
every thousand players that might be
good at some of these negotiating
tactics or things like that but as a
whole players play football okay
and players the other issue here Mike
that would just scare me as like Pires
are pleasers like that they want to
please everybody in the organization
they really are I want to play football
I want my coach to like me because I
play hard and do all those things and I
perform in the field and the same
feelings are for the owners and if the
owner got in there a year and this type
of things yeah I think they would make
players bend to things where they would
go two years down the road why the hell
did I think of their do that yeah I
agree with you completely I mean put
yourself in that spot Chris if when you
were playing for the Buccaneers Jon
Gruden brings you into the office and
you think you're gonna talk about the
game plan or watch film and he decides
he wants to hammer out your contract
right there forget about the GM forget
about the agent let's just get this done
I mean it should cause for any player
who's in that spot the alarms to start
blaring yeah you don't want to do that
you don't want to let yourself get
influenced by that pressure because
that's why you have an agent you step
away from the process so you don't have
to deal with those people that you work
for yeah yeah you know the the the
owners are masters of this this is why
they're successful business people and
it's not gonna be like at like it's at
face value I would sure I'm sure a lot
of things would look the same if a
player negotiated this contract as
compared to an agent where you go I mean
look at that number that's such a big
number that's sexy it's the little
intricate details of a contract that the
agents worth the protections you know
the guarantees for injury
all of those little things that really a
player is not going to be nuanced about
where the agent really comes in handy
yeah the player knows the borderline I
want this much money and this much
guaranteed but it's all the other stuff
that's really important and that's the
worth of the agent all right let's move
along to the concept of replay review
for pass interference and there's a
bunch of different angles here that we
have talked about in recent weeks one
thing that really crystallized for me
yesterday when talking to NFL senior VP
of officiating our River on the
procedure for handling Hail Mary plays
now there was talk at one point about
coming up with a formula for when it was
a Hail Mary when it's not some objective
thing how many yards how many guys in
the end zone
they've altima Lee decided this and Kris
I'm always a little nervous when there's
a procedure that isn't reflected in the
rule book and the procedure is they
treat pass interference differently on
Hail Mary plays they just do they
tolerate contact there that you wouldn't
tolerate during a normal play but
there's nothing in the rule book
allowing that and that in and of itself
because you want to know what the
standard is what's the rule well it's
just what we think it is and it's just
you know you know what when you see it
well sometimes you think you see it but
you don't see it and sometimes you think
you know it but you don't know it yeah
but here's what I know
our River Ron said yesterday that for
Hail Mary plays that do have this
different standard that that different
standard is gonna be part of replay
review so this loose certain amounts of
contact are okay on a Hail Mary play
that's the same standard that our River
on is gonna apply easier said than done
yes because it's one thing to be in the
scrum and not pull your flag out in that
moment it's another thing to be watching
the film after the fact seeing the
visual evidence and maybe you see
something you say hmmm you know where
the line is no we don't know the line
you're right
and it really it mean they're opening
Pandora's box for a lot of public
criticism with this type of stuff I mean
they really are because you're right
it's a Hail Mary there could be you know
eight 10 guys all in a mosh pit right
and from the very definition of P I in
the rule book there's a lot of passion
in fairness that goes on in those type
of situations but I
what I get from out River on and listen
to him talk more than anything it's
going to have to be overly egregious in
a Hail Mary type of situation for them
to call it like literally a DBS and they
have to jump on the back of a receiver
and you know put him in a headlock or
really pull the Jersey to where we see a
jersey like extend and go oh my gosh
yeah the guy can't jump and the we see a
shoulder pad because the jerseys been
pulled that far I guess it's going to be
those type of things but you're right
we're gonna watch replays and people are
gonna go that's past interference that's
past interference and our River runs
gonna have to explain to people not on a
Hail Mary and it's just gonna cause
criticism and uproar everywhere and I
hope that he can adhere to that higher
bar when he is watching frame by frame
I've seen him explain some plays from
last year that weren't called
interference on the field that he claims
would be called interference under this
new standard and it concerns me because
I personally believe that the bar should
be as I've said before what the hell as
in if you see it and they don't throw
the flag what the hell's going on here
I've got to be that blatant and a lot of
these plays when he shows it I can see
why he says after the fact
it's pass interference but it's not so
glaring and it's not so blade that I
think you should disregard the
subjective judgment of the officials on
the field yes and in the Hail Marys
setting it's gonna be even more of a
challenge because he's gonna see
something in slow motion that the
officials didn't see and what's he gonna
do then and how do you ensure
consistency when again there isn't a
rule where what is it you can't say you
know it when you see it as the official
rulebook and if that's the case out of
line in the rule book for Hail Mary
plays we will know them when we see them
and when Hail Mary plays happen we will
know what is permissible and what isn't
what what god that's no way to run the
National Football League and I'm not
saying I have a better suggestion but I
just I think it's dangerous to have no
standard for spotting a Hail Mary play
when you activate this looser standard
and to have no articulated standard of
what the looser standard is Cris and
then on top of all of it you're gonna
try to apply that standard to replay
review this has the potential to be a
huge problem in the wrong game high
profile regular-season game
playoff game Super Bowl it's got the
potential to be a nightmare for the NFL
bigger than the nightmare that his cause
replay review to descend on pass
interference can be and again this is
why I was not in favor of any of this I
really wasn't I mean it was I know it
was a horrible mistake but it was one in
fifty-three years or at least one in my
lifetime that I can really look at and
go ooh that was so horrible I've never
seen anything like that and yes I think
in a lot of ways you know it's really
the the basic fan who just turns on
football on Sundays and doesn't really
pay attention to it and maybe it's just
a little bit of like a fantasy person so
I want to say maybe less than the basic
fan is what I'm saying you know I think
they're gonna see a lot of plays like
you're talking about where they're gonna
go
wait this is being reviewed and that
looks like pass interference to me and
Rhonda I mean our River on is going to
err on the side of the judgment that was
called in the field and it's going to
have to be overly egregious for him to
overturn some of these plays he's not
just gonna let like a hand on the
shoulder go oh yep that was pass
interference yep
throw that flag out there we're
overturning that call know from what
we've seen in the examples we've seen
it's gonna have to be something really
stunning even on replay to go he
definitely hindered significantly the
wide receiver trying to catch a football
well let's hope that's the case let's
hope that this solution doesn't make the
problem even worse than it was all right
the NFL has a preseason problem insofar
as the preseason is too long and the
linkage of shortening the preseason and
expanding the regular season diminishing
the connection between shortening the
preseason and expanding the playoffs
gaining momentum Marc masky the
Washington Post had a story on Wednesday
Chris that expanded playoffs a more
likely replacement for part of the
preseason than expanded regular season
we talked about expanded playoffs
yesterday I know you're not a fan of
them but you know one thing I want to
make clear the NFL has the ability to
shrink the preseason anytime they want
they just don't want to do it without a
way to offset the revenue they will lose
course they seem to think they can
expand the playoffs without the consent
of the NFL PA they're wrong on that or
they would have done it already the NFL
Players Association has to agree to the
addition of games even
only two more games now I personally
think if you're gonna have extra games
in the wild-card round and make the
two-seed play the seven seed who
currently doesn't get in
I think the eight seed needs to be in
and the one seed needs to play that
weekend I don't like the idea of only
one team per conference getting a by
making that advantage even stronger
making that one seed even more valuable
making the presumption even stronger
that the one seed is going to the Super
Bowl I don't like that I say if you're
going to expand it expand it to 16 make
the 1 seed play wildcard round and and
have four extra wildcard games not to
Chris what do you think well I mean I
don't really necessarily like that I
don't I mean first off then you know
yeah I mean what's the body even want to
be the 1 seed really I mean ok I mean I
just did that's a great play the 8 seed
in the 8 seeds the worst team in the
playoffs ok great I mean so what I mean
my mobile some teams might go damn it
looks like the seven teams worse than
the 18 let's let's be the 2 seed you
know there's got to be some reward for
winning the regular season more than
just that itself and I do think that I
of course like the current status and I
don't like the no buy thing no that's
yes it's an advantage for the teams that
have the by I get that they've earned it
by winning in the regular season and and
now they get a week of rest to be at
their absolute best sets everybody
else's fault that's not their fault so I
don't necessarily like that I would like
to find you know if we're gonna do it
I saw one explanation of maybe all four
division winners get a bye on the first
weekend and then the 5 through 8 scanned
of play each other and then they figure
out how to match and mix and match the
next sophs
you know next round however maybe either
way I don't want to see it before I
confuse this situation but boy wait wait
that's not gonna create more games in
the wild-card round you're gonna have
more okay you're gonna have five through
eight in each conference play each other
in the wild-card round you still have
the same number of games yeah no I know
it's not gonna it's still gonna have the
same number of games but at least
there's a reward for some teams to win
their division and get a first round bye
I mean I am in favor of that first off
second of all I don't want it anyway so
your way you
talking about an extra round right
you're talking about okay so there would
be there would be a pre wild-card round
where five through eight Whittle them
down to two teams and then you start
with the normal wild-card round then the
division
you know it's an extra week of football
here's the thing it adds an extra week
and it pushes the Super Bowl one week
closer to Presidents Day weekend which
the NFL want love to do and maybe maybe
the ultimate end result here is two
preseason games 17 regular season games
and that five through eight extra round
of the wild-card a pre wild-card round I
kind of like that and but then here's
what happens yeah here's here's what
happens the one in the two seat Chris
end up getting to by can do byes yes I
know and I don't even know if that's a
good thing either I know that's scary
that's scary so yeah I mean I guess I
have to like you know work this through
my brain a little but also what I'm
scared of is just a watered-down product
to a degree a little bit you know
there's been years where I just go you
know I know we've had years where the
six seeds been phenomenal we've seen the
succeed when the Super Bowl go to the
Super Bowl do all those things and yes
but there's been other years where I
think we all go damn the six seed they
stink the five seed they stink they have
no chance so five six seven and eight I
want to go I don't even want to see them
this is a waste of time and that's what
I worry about too a little bit so that's
my thought yeah you're letting half the
league into the playoffs and how many is
too many and if you got 32 teams is 16
too many and and that's why I think if
they do it it's gonna be 14 they're
gonna add two extra wildcard games they
will be and and I think they do what
they need to do is take advantage of
Monday night play one of those wildcard
games on Monday night and make sure that
whoever wins doesn't play until the
following Sunday so they at least have
you know some rest right before they
play their next game or or have that
winner play the following Monday but if
they want to generate the revenue the
kind of revenue is gonna offset the loss
of the preseason they need to take full
advantage of the primetime windows and
they're currently staying away from
Monday night they need to embrace Sunday
night and Saturday night as much as they
possibly can in the wild-card round all
right next up we've talked a lot about
Carli Lloyd and her aspiration to become
a kicker in the National Football League
Keenan Allen
had some pushback recently on Twitter
basically saying yeah it's all fine
until there's a kick block and then it's
like the Stampede scene from The Lion
King III I don't like the presumption
that Carli Lloyd's not gonna be able to
take care of herself because she's a
woman
look at some of the kickers over the
years who have been required to take
care of themselves in a difficult
situation whether it's Garrow your
premium who had one of the most
embarrassing moments of NFL history with
that gaffe in Super Bowl seven when he
decided to try to throw the ball when
all hell broke loose
rich Carlos was running around out there
without a shoe and a sock on one leg and
that was considered sufficiently safe
and then he got the gramática brothers
you know we did the celebration that
tears the ACL I mean they're been plenty
of unathletic who have to go run and
hide and take cover when all hell breaks
loose on the football field I don't know
why that would be any different for
Carly Lord I mean a hundred percent I
mean and Mike you made the point during
one of our commercial breaks cuz we
talked about this for a second during
the show today you said look at some
quarterbacks in the NFL yeah I could
point out a lot of quarterbacks where
they might as well just lay down after
they threw the interception they're
doing nothing they're running down the
field to make it look like they're going
after somebody but when it comes time to
like take on the block or make the
tackle
oh they somehow miss or slipping and we
don't we don't want them to know we
don't want do you want Aaron Rodgers to
sprint down the field to try to make the
tackle and pull his hams not if not
unless it's the playoffs as a Super Bowl
or a game to get into the playoff
something like that it has to be a big
moment you're right the worth of his
team the work his worth to the team is
far greater than him making that tackle
and maybe getting hurt and then being
done for the year so I'm with you on
this fight on the way I don't even care
if Carli Lloyd can field goal gets
blocked I mean if she just falls down
and sits there fine
that's fine with me I don't care most
kickers they're basically doing that
anyways they're just trying to please
their coach by like look my arms are
moving in my arm my legs are moving I'm
running yeah great you're running you're
not trying to do anything so I'm with
you I'm not worried about that aspect of
it think of how many teams right now are
struggling to find a reliable kicker if
you can inspire soccer players who
happen to be female to aspire to and
train
to become football kickers and maybe
decide when they're eight years old not
when they're 37 like Carli Lloyd is that
this is something they want to do you
are expanding your pool of available
talent because clearly there are females
who can kick the hell out of a football
you may as well identify it nurture it
get it in high school football
college football and that's the way to
do it and and that's why this Carli
Lloyd thing is important because there
are going to be girls coast-to-coast who
see this and say I think I want to do
that and I think I can do that and 20
years from now one of them will be doing
that if not sooner yeah I I'm hoping so
I hope it does go that way I think it
would be good for the sport in a lot of
different areas of course grow the sport
maybe give a little more knowledge to
people out there who were scared of
football altogether to realize okay this
isn't like as barbaric as I thought it
is and you know not all these people are
bad or jerks and yeah I'm with you I
hope it happens I hope it Carli Lloyd
goes for it next year I really am one
last point I want to tap into your Jon
Gruden experience from your time in
Tampa Bay Gruden said earlier this week
that he wants the team to take more
vertical shots in the passing game this
year they've got better receivers
they've got a better line and also
there's that chance that you throw out
the red challenge flag and even if the
pass was incomplete al river on
determines that there was defensive pass
interference how much of that is
directed at the quarterback and how much
pressure does it put on Derek Carr to
deliver those deep balls that Jon Gruden
wants yeah I think it's totally directed
at the quarterback I mean that to me and
just my you know my thesaurus of cryptic
Jon Gruden language right basically what
he's saying is we're not being
aggressive enough in practice I got
these weapons called Antonio Brown
Tyrell Williams and JJ Nelson who can
fly and we got to stop worrying about
completion percentage or you know taking
the easy way out and hitting the 4-yard
shallow cross when Antonio Brown you
know is got to step on a guy 50 yards
down the field he wants it to be
launched down there it's the name of the
game right now I do think the day and
age of like oh we're gonna dink and dunk
and throw three and four yard passes
we're seeing a kind of go away and I
know the Saints are getting away
the Saints are special Sean Payton
special they also have one of the best
old lines and football and a run game
that helps all that to would the Taysom
Hill package but for everybody else and
you've heard me say this before
other than turnovers the number one play
that dictates winning and losing games
is plus 20-yard plays explosive plays in
a football game and I think that's where
Jon Gruden sees it defenses have gotten
used to you know all these short passes
these wide receiver screens bubble
screens all of those things
that's why Seattle's defense became so
popular it took away all that crap too
now I think we're seeing a little bit of
an old-school mentality and I will say I
think Derek Carr has been a little bit
less aggressive the last few years and
I'm sure John goon sees that and he's
trying to kind of push him into that
into that mode and I really do think
that that this is the year that Derek
Carr has to become the guy that Jon
Gruden is comfortable with or next year
we're gonna be talking about someone
else playing quarterback for the Oakland
Raiders this is the test when they are
the Las Vegas Raiders next year yeah
alright that's it for this Thursday pft
ot Chris enjoy your birthday is there
are you doing a Chris Sims on button
today I am I'm gonna do that here in a
little bit so yeah NFC over unders we're
gonna talk some ball and even dive into
a little Notre Dame in college football
just a little bit today since the big
effort wasn't there when you were born
is he gonna be involved in your birthday
edition of Chris Simms unbuttoned nope
he's not he's got to go on the road and
do something for CBS so he cannot come
on today I'm just hoping I get knowing
my dad I'll get a phone call like 11:30
tonight going hey happy birthday that's
how my dad usually works you'll remember
around 11 o'clock tonight that it was my
birthday
all right well Chris happy birthday have
a great day buddy and we'll see you next
week thanks man see ya
[Music]
you